[MUSIC]
CHIA-YING WANG: The purpose
of this laboratory course
is to introduce students
with modern techniques
of experimental
physical chemistry,
and inorganic chemistry.
One of the projects is
building a spectrometer.
So the students really
build these from scratch.
They really have this
firsthand experience
about how to build a
homemade optical setup,
and that's usually
only experience
for graduate students.
PHIL BROOKS: It was a
really independent project
putting all the components
together, and we
had to code up the whole
interface to run the machine,
using special
laboratory software,
and learn about optics,
learn about controls.
If you're actually doing
state-of-the-art research,
you really need to know
how the machine is working.
So this project gave all of us
a really in-depth understanding
of how an absorbance
spectrometer works
and what sort of things
could go wrong with it
and what its limitations are
that you might not otherwise
get.
[MUSIC PLAYING]